bonsoir à la napster merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france invoque est
à johannesbourg il expliqué nous
concrètement qu elle est là la situation
sur place
la situation ici est grave
les hôpitaux sont pleins même les
hôpitaux privés au privé les hôpitaux de
l'état
nous n'avons que vacciner que 1% de la
pop hip de la population est maintenant
c'est très difficile de trouver un livre
franchement de trouver liés il faut
attend que quelqu'un est décédé pour
rentrer dans les hôpitaux
et il ya plusieurs raisons pourquoi de
la faction le dévouement des vaccins de
vaccination est-elle si on en est là
c'est à cause d'eux il ya beaucoup de
pays riches qui ont acheté des massifs
stocks de vaccins et puis le astrazeneca
il y avait un recherche locale qui
donnait le résultat que les vaccins
n'étaient pas si efficaces contre le coc
vie donc légères et modérées
donc on arrêtait le déroulement la vente
du lait vexin d'astrazeneca
puis on a commencé avec les gens de cnn
johnson et après à moi de vous le
déroulement de jocelyn jack johnson on a
trouvé des quelques thrombose dans les
états unis donc on a arrêté encore le
déroulement de vaccination ici en
afrique du sud
et puis maintenant compte en a besoin
d'acheter sur le sirom d india on a
trouvé les crises on line en ans l'inde
était si grave que elle ne peut pas
donner les dosettes dans les pays en
afrique
donc voilà où nous sommes nous sommes
maintenant air de schiste oui pardonnez
moi on sent vraiment peut-être un manque
de chance dans la stratégie parce que
c'est vrai que le gouvernement on
imagine ne pouvait peut-être pas
anticiper tous les problèmes dont vous
nous parler
veut dire que voilà ils ont misé sur des
vaccins malheureusement qui se sont
avérés ne pas être forcément les les
bons en tout cas avec une défiance pour
ce qui est de d'astrazeneca rolls et en
europe aussi
oui non c'est vrai parce que c'est pas
tout à fait leur faute mais aussi on n'a
pas préparé dès les débuts de cette
pandémie d'acheter les vaccins à l'heure
et maintenant les chiffres augmentent
chaque jour 2 en janvier férié il y
avait presque un mille nouveaux cas
maintenant ce salaire à 13000 est
aujourd'hui lé hier c'était 17000 et
16000 avec 166 morts
aujourd'hui donc la pique va arriver
dans deux semaines donc ces mêmes ces
situations maintenant est grave mais ça
va aggraver davantage dans les
prochaines semaines aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on est en décalage avec
l'afrique du sud qui semblait quand même
mieux se porter d'ailleurs le continent
africain
de manière globale se portait mieux que
l'europe l'europe va mieux
quel est le regard de médecins que vous
portez sur voilà ces décalages en
fonction des continents des pays mêmes
on a pris deux buts à 2 du retard contre
les autres pays en afrique australien au
même on est dernier à bangui pour soi le
nigeria sénégal avec le déroulement de
vaccination d'un coup moi c'est une
c'est très grave que ce soit le cas mais
il faut faire le meilleur ce qu'on peut
faire avec le vaccin ona on a déjà
acheté à jeudi environ 50 millions de
doses de johnson & johnson
mais pour le moment c'est trop tard et
ce qui m'inquiète ce troisième vague va
encore qu'un temps va être atteint par
la troisième vague eux ils ne sont pas
dans le troisième va actuellement c'est
seulement 35 pétroliers à johannesburg
et les médecins soro sont est cuit
et nous sommes presque au bout des
lèvres de nos forces et il faut
s'occuper plusieurs gens chaque jour et
c'est presque impossible de soigner un
tel nombre de médecins malades avec le
co vie c'est vraiment c'est impossible
clairement vous en tant que médecin
malgré les problèmes dont vous nous avez
parlé sur ses vaccins dhainaut virus
sras et michael johnson johnson est ce
que vous encourager vraiment la
population à se faire vacciner est ce
que là à nos gouvernements les autorités
en font assez en matière de
communication on croit savoir que le
ministre de la santé d'ailleurs a été
suspendu et ce qu'ils en font assez dans
cette pédagogie bénéfice risque ça c'est
très important c'est vraiment c'est
peut-être de ne pas prendre le vaccin
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est parce que
le il y avait six cas de thrombose
vasculaire aux états unis et puis qu'on
a trouvé que la vaccination et necker
n'était pas si efficaces contre le coc
vide légèrement à thème modéré atteint
sa seule et les doutes dans les gens en
disant voilà le vaccin n'est n'est pas
100%
il n'y a pas cent soixante sécurité
contre le coc vie mais si on est
vaccinés ça va vous protéger contre les
locaux vides grave et dès qu'on est
gravement malade avec le co vite
vraiment c'est la chance de qu'on peut
survivre dans ce cas c'est vraiment on
ne sait pas c'est 1% sécurité dont on va
sortir de l'hôpital le variant delta de
variants indien cause est la cause de
tous les maux en afrique du sud et le
sera aussi pour l'afrique un lot msa eu
des propos très alarmiste aujourd'hui
sur sur l'afrique qui pourrait beaucoup
souffrir de de ce variant oui il y a
encore maintenant le vin rayon delta
plus ici en afrique du sud
mais heureusement il n'y a pas des
recherches qui montrent que ces variants
sont plus meurtriers je dirais mais
c'est plus insidieux et
c'est c'est difficile avec de vivre avec
le co vide presque une en un an et demi
parce que les gens sont fatigués ils
commencent à se mélanger ensemble ils
commencent à fait baisser les masques
d'aller au restaurant ça on a besoin
dans la restriction sociale à mon avis
en ce moment on est sûr nouveau 3 même
je crois on va à toulouse près ce
nouveau 4 dans les prochains jours merci
beaucoup en tout cas l anah peter
médecins généralistes merci en tout cas
nous avoir apporté votre témoignage et
bon courage en tout cas à vous